let's talk about sports today the first
big day of March Madness and the games
that started this morning at nine right
here on CBS but even if maybe you're not
a sports expert maybe you can't name the
teams or really don't know any of the
rules of the game it doesn't matter
there's a lot of fun to be had Laura
negrenny joining us live from the South
Point sports book so they got a bucket
of beers they got all kinds of fun
things Lauren have you been practicing
your free throws yet
yes I have been practicing let the
record show I did make a couple let's
hope that that record that that
continues that look as we go to the next
block but for now yeah great uh Ambiance
here there's already 50 people lining up
outside I'm joined by Ryan to talk more
about why those people are out here you
know what to expect uh they're excited
this is actually the first time it's
ever been in this room though and the
reason it's a free entry most
importantly I have 2 000 seats 10
betting Windows 6 betting kiosk on you
can sign up for our online app but then
you got to get into the food and drink
specials we're talking two dollar hot
dogs five dollar chicken fingers six
dollar loaded nachos seven dollar Shrimp
Po Boys twenty dollars gonna get you a
bucket of beer and if you don't want to
pay for twenty dollars for a bucket of
beer we're gonna go over to that
basketball court if you can make four
out of five free throws we're going to
give you a free bucket of beer if Beer's
not your taste well we got four dollar
Tito's four dollar pendletons I don't
know what else you could ask for I think
it's going to be crazy here today but
that's why they call it this is the
massive Madness biggest massive Madness
party in Las Vegas oh man we're looking
forward to that and like we said we're
gonna get over there and try our hand at
that free throw line you gotta you gotta
wait for this next Vlog to see me do
that but again we're gonna be talking
more about sports betting out here and
then just the sports venue viewing
option here at Southpoint back to you
guys she wants more time to practice
Yeah well she's all stalling yeah I just
started looking at the bracket just now
I'm picking I'm going for Colgate
Colgate I don't know why the toothpaste
no the school Colgate University Upstate
New York see I can still have fun all
right 609 uh thank you very much Lauren
appreciate it